what we're going to do in this video is
think about the rise of Empires and make
the comparison with four very early
empires that we have studied a key
minted Persia the Maurya Empire in India
Han China and the Roman Empire so let's
just start with a general framework so
the first question is what is an empire
a broad definition of an empire is when
one group has control over a fairly
diverse population one group has control
over another group that might have
different linguistic practices different
culture that's when it is considered an
empire well what's the general framework
for how empires tend to form well let's
say that I am a ruler and I control this
territory right over here and either
through my charisma my military tactics
maybe I have a new weapon some political
intrigue some weak neighbors I'm able to
conquer some more territory right over
here what does that do for me as I
expand this gives me more land and more
people to rule over and I can tax that
land and people to have more wealth and
larger armies and so these two things
are pretty good ingredients to be able
to take on even more of my neighbors and
expand even further and so you might say
well why doesn't that process just keep
on going on indefinitely well it does go
pretty far you see you see these various
empires are quite large especially when
you consider the technology of the time
the communications ability of the time
but at some point you might have weak
leadership you might have trouble
controlling these large and spread out
empires especially if you can't
communicate if you can't get good
information but now let's dive a little
bit deeper into the four empires we just
referred to so let's start with the key
mitad persia founded in 550 bc
by Cyrus degrade this is so far in the
past that most of our accounts of how
Cyrus comes to power come from the
Greeks who were not friends with the
Persians they were famous rivals but one
thing comes clear in the narrative which
is that Cyrus the Great was considered a
very strong and effective leader so I
would definitely put leadership there he
starts off as a relatively minor King
subject - you could say the Emperor of
Metis who is his grandfather and he is
able to overthrow him but because of his
military leadership his ability to bring
people into the fold he was known as
being tolerant of the people he would
rule over that that all helped him
control and expand a large empire so I
would say leadership is definitely first
for Cyrus the Great and then I would say
culture would be part of it now let's
think about Moria
India Moria India was founded by Chandra
Gupta Moria and here once again I would
say leadership was a major factor he was
aided by his political adviser
Chanakya who's famous in Indian history
for his strategic thinking
Chandragupta Maurya legend has it met
Alexander the Great when he came into
the Indus but once Alexander the Great
left there was a power vacuum you could
say that that power vacuum helped the
Maurya Empire be founded it's similar to
the notion of having weaker neighbors
once Alexander the Great left and so Han
China Han China is interesting the first
emperors of Han China aren't the ones to
first unify China that happens under the
Qin Dynasty qi n qin dynasty that
preceded the han dynasty and they were
able to do that by being very strong
very authoritarian very centralized but
once the Qin Emperor dies it leaves a
clear power vacuum and then you have a
succession battle but eventually the han
dynasty is formed one of the ways that
the Han Dynasty is able to keep power
despite not being as authoritarian as
the Qin is that they revitalize
Confucianism
and use that ideology and use that
culture in order to more unify the
Chinese people the Roman Empire we study
in some detail it's hard to pin a date
on exactly when it becomes an empire on
this timeline this first period right
over here is when we have the Roman
Kingdom then you have the Roman Republic
and then you have the Roman Empire and
so you could debate when it actually
becomes an empire even when it was an
early Kingdom it was conquering
neighboring people on the Italian
peninsula and at that time period it
might have felt like an empire because
those people might have felt different
as time passed and they were under a
unified state under a unified Kingdom
they probably felt more similar but then
when they conquered even more territory
that might have felt more and more like
an empire but what is clear is even as
we get into the late Republic period it
was an empire Julius Caesar famously
conquered Gaul these Germanic peoples
before coming back and essentially
taking control to be succeeded by the
first official Roman Empire after a long
and bloody civil war Augustus Caesar
these other three empires happened
relatively quickly we're talking within
a period of less than 50 years while the
Roman Empire took hundreds of years to
form and so it's hard to ascribe the
Empire to any one leader you could say
that there was a culture of expansion
one could make the argument that they
were more technologically sophisticated
than some of their neighbors especially
when it came to military might and as is
expanded it definitely was able to take
advantage of weak neighbors so now let's
just take a step back what we've done in
this exercise is a rough approximation
of the various dimensions that might
lead to an empire rising it's by no
means comprehensive and I suggest for
you to think about what dimensions would
you add to this maybe you could add a
political dimension or maybe that's
captured by leadership maybe you would
add an economic dimension how much
wealth a nation has and as we go forward
in history we're going to see different
weights on these different
engines for how important they are for
Empire formation especially as we get
closer and closer to modern times
technology increases as a factor in
terms of creating an empire ideology
plays a significant role and empires
based on religion but we also have
empires based on economic ideology
communism versus capitalism and on
political ideology and does an empire
have to be strict control can you have a
cultural Empire without necessarily
having direct control over people so I
will leave you with these questions
they're fascinating questions to think
about within the context of these
empires but also as we study all of
world history